>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
[Pause]
>> Elizabeth Peterson:
Hello everyone.
My name is Betsy Peterson.
I'm the Director of the
American Folklife Center here
at the Library of Congress.
And on behalf of
the staff and I want
to welcome you all here
today to the latest
in our ongoing Benjamin
Botkin lecture series.
A word about the Botkin series,
it's an opportunity to allow AFC
to highlight the latest and best
scholarship by leading scholars
in the disciplines of folklore,
oral history, ethnomusicology
and cultural heritage while
enhancing the collections here
at the American Folklife Center.
For the center and the library
the Botkin lectures are an
important facet of our
acquisition activities.
Each lecture is video
tapped and becomes part
of the permanent collections.
In addition the lectures will
be later posted as webcasts
on the library's website.
So with that said if I could ask
you if you have a cell phone on
or any other electronic
device please turn it off
at this point.
One of the giant's in
the field of folklore
and especially British
American folk music is Francis
James Child.
A legendary 19th century
Bostonian scholar whose research
and classification of 305
British Isle ballads was
so seminole to the field
that folklorists still refer
to the narrative
songs he included
in his magnum opus the English
and Scottish popular ballads
as simply as Child ballads.
If you have even the
remotest interest
in folk music I have a
feeling you've probably heard
about the Child ballads
numerous times.
His contributions as
a public intellectual
and scholar were deeply
influential in the establishment
and development of literature
and folklore departments
at universities throughout
the United States.
And also intertwined with the
broader history and development
of American intellectual
history.
He remains however kind of a
remote figure which is a chain
because his personal story
is as complex and compelling
as the plotlines of
any of the ballads.
So today's speaker,
Michael J. Bell,
will be discussing
his recent research
on Child's correspondence
and other previously unexplored
Child related materials
that has allowed him to
reconstruct Child's life,
his personal and professional
networks and his contributions
to America's 19th century
intellectual landscape.
Michael Bell and I, I just
as a parenthetical aside,
there are few Michael Bell's
in the field of folklore.
And he is Michael J. Bell.
Michael is a folklorist
who received his doctorate
in folklore and folklife from
the University of Pennsylvania.
He began his academic
career as a professor
at Detroit's Wayne State
University and later moved
to Grinnell College in Iowa.
His early work includes
the classic study,
the World from Brown's
Lounge, An Ethnology
of Black Middle Class Play which
was published by University
of Illinois press in 1982.
Bell's career took him down
more administrative pathways.
He recently retired as
Vice President and Dean
of the University
at Transylvania University
in Lexington.
But we're delighted that he
is returned back to the fold
of folklore in history and the
development of our discipline.
So please join me
in welcoming him
for a Botkin lecture entitled
My Secret Autobiography,
Letters of Ballad Scholar
Francis James Child
to William Ellery Sedgwick.
Dr. Michael J. Bell.
[ Applause ]
>> Michael Bell: I've recently
had cataract surgery so I have
to now learn after 65
years to put glasses
on before I begin to read.
I'll try not to make this too
much of a paper presentation
but I am going to be reading
excerpts from letters.
And since they were written
they have to be read aloud
and I'll be looking down
more than I would like.
Thanks to the Library
of Congress
and especially the American
Folklife Center and especially,
especially to Nancy Gross
for this opportunity.
I can get very excited
about Child.
I will try to stay mild
mannered as long as I can.
I will be and thank you
Betsy for the introduction.
I can skip a couple of
features that I already,
that I thought I had to put in.
You all now know
who Francis Child is
and I can move on
to the letters.
Just a quick word however
about William Ellery Sedgwick.
He is, as you will hear
in the paper, but I wanted
to say he was Child's
college roommate at Harvard.
He is a member the, the Sedgwick
family including Kyra Sedgwick,
Edie Sedgwick, Theodore
Sedgwick and a large passel
of other Sedgwicks across
the 19th and 20th century.
They were for the longest
time and probably still are,
though we don't know
it, one of the,
if not the wealthiest family
as family in the United States.
And they've, he himself
in later life turns
into an Edith Wharton novel.
You will all actually have read
it but maybe not recognized it.
His, that is Ellery Sedgwick's
wife Charlotte left him,
ran away with her lover to
Europe and lived there in sin
and then in marriage
for many years.
And then returned
to the United States
with the following
condition put on her, by her,
to the Sedgwick family.
I will be received by all
of my daughter's friends
otherwise we will not return
to the United States.
That is an Edith Wharton novel.
It's also a section of
Princess Casimir by Henry James.
So I won't be talking
directly about Elliot.
You are still connected to
sort of the world we're going
to be entering in a second.
My Secret Autobiography,
The Early Letters
of Francis James Child to
William Ellery Sedgwick.
If in your wanderings in
the library shelves you were
to come upon this series, The
British Poets from Chaucer
to Wordsworth, published
by Little, Brown and edited
by Francis James Child.
And if you were to take
down from that collection,
the first of its eight volumes
of English and Scottish ballads,
selected and edited by
that selfsame Child.
And if you were to turn
to its dedication page you
would read the following:
to William Ellery
Sedgwick of New York,
this collection is
affectionately dedicated.
If you were a general reader
you might idle for a moment,
wonder who this Sedgwick
person was and then page on.
If you were a folklorist
or a ballad scholar
or an English professor
or perhaps an interested
anthropologist you might pause
for a minute longer
and wonder not only
who was this Sedgwick
person but why he
of all people was the
object of Child's affection.
Was he somehow connected
to Child's lifelong study
of the ballad, perhaps an
unknown ballad scholar,
a hither to unrecognized
intimate
with whom Child exchanged
his early opinions
and ideas on balladry?
In part you would
wonder because for all
of his fame Child is
scholarly mystery.
Despite the fact that he
is one of the founders
of the discipline of English
studies and one of the founders
of American folklore studies
that he remains the longest
serving Harvard English
professor, 45 years, and
that his later magnum opus,
The English and Scottish
Popular Ballads,
is debatably the greatest
work ever published
by any American folklorist.
We simply do not know enough
about Child to allow us either
to take the measure
of the scholar
or the measure of the man.
Child never wrote an
introduction to his English
and Scottish Popular Ballads.
And that absence meant that
his work remains unfinished
and we its readers cannot
parse either his intentions
or its full meaning.
Our knowledge of Child the
man offers us no substitute
for our ignorance of
Child the scholar,
feel personal anecdote
exist and most of his known
or published correspondence
does not contain much in the way
of personal history
or private sentiment.
The first problem
cannot be solved.
Child will not write
his introduction.
And we cannot write it for him.
We can guess at what
he would have written.
We can argue over the
arguments he might have made.
We might even assert that his
work was a failure deserving
neither attention
nor our praise.
But no matter our approach
we are left fighting
against a silence that
cannot be overcome.
However solving the
second problem offers,
holds greater hope.
Recent discoveries of
personal letters such as those
of his wife, Elizabeth
Ellery Sedgwick Child,
held at the Clements Library
of the University of Michigan,
the Child family papers held by
the Cambridge Historical Society
and most importantly the Frances
James Child William Ellery
Sedgwick correspondence held
at the Massachusetts Historical
Society give us an opportunity
to meet the young man who
would eventually become the
great collector.
Consider this presentation
then as an beginning exercise
in psychological deduction.
My goal today is
to try to allow you
to meet Francis James Child
before he became Francis James
Child, before in a sense he
became the name of a kind
of traditional ballad.
The full collection of letters
is a truly revealing catalogue
of Child's private sentiments
written from 1846 to,
from 1846 to 1863 and consisting
of over 400 letters from Child
to his closest friend,
college roommate
and eventual brother-in-law,
William Ellery Sedgwick.
The letters as Child
described them chapters
from his secret autobiography
constitute a powerful epistolary
narration of Child's passage
from recent college graduate
to beginning Harvard professor.
Because there is not
enough time today
to explicate the
entire correspondence,
I will concentrate on several of
the 127 letters written by him
from his graduation in 1846 to
his first fulltime appointment
at Harvard as the Boylston
Professor of Rhetoric in 1851.
Unfortunately the story
will be a monologue.
Inexplicably for the age none
of Ellery Sedgwick's responses
to Child were preserved
by Child or his family.
Not surprisingly the letters
from these years
express iconic themes
for a young single recent
college graduate moving
from age 21 to age 27.
Like many of us at that
age Child is concerned
with all the ordinary
traumas that arise
from college graduation,
his renewed relations
with his family,
his college loans,
his need to find a job and love.
Eventually all four
concerns will converge
in a wrenching series of
letters written from early 1848
to just months before his
return from Europe in 1851.
But more on that later.
First let me introduce Child as
he sets the rules in late 1846
for his epistolary monologue.
Dear Ell [Phonetic], he
writes, may I fearlessly confess
that I often want to speak out
feelings that would be snubbed
as unbecoming or
rejected as pretentious.
How seldom have I been able
to unfold myself completely
even half an hour of myself,
a few minutes, and how false
and oppressive have I
experienced those equal claims
which keep me from giving
myself to the higher sentiments
which we all love to see
confessed in a play or a poem.
But bear not utter
for fear of man.
And then as if to confirm
both those higher sentiments
and the freedom he
seeks describing a trip
that was never taken
but planned.
Child continues, my dearest
boy, don't think that I'm not
with you in our plans
for Europe.
I put on the mask of Peleus
but for a moment thou shalt
be marius on the ruins
and I shall sketch thee.
We will handle the arms of
the Sid, offer up shillings
to all the showmen of Athens,
[Inaudible] the prima donna
at San Carlos, drink tokay
with Metternich and hoc
with the grand dukes, drop
a tear on every monument
in Westminster Abbey, buy every
good book in the London shops,
beat the Frenchmen in amusements
and the German in study,
take better general views
than Ramez [Phonetic]
and better gossip than
Basil Hall [Phonetic]
with such glorious
realities in sight,
who thinks of the
insubstantial phantom, money.
The answer of course
was Child for whom money
and status were anything
but insubstantial.
Have you any faith to
ask a new light question,
he begins another
letter and continues.
I haven't the slightest.
Though always a little
inclined to affect sad fancies.
I was happy enough as a boy and
being of very sensitive feelings
and rather a religious
temperament, I had plenty
of expressions of a lively kind.
To however things
went I was active.
Life was busy and interesting
whether painful or otherwise.
I had many hard times but
always weathered them.
Years have gone by and I am
extremely much better situated
than ever.
I have materials of happiness
around me that I never expected
to possess and I am
less happy than ever.
Worst of all I feel dead.
The future has no inviting hopes
and to my solidity few fears
therefore I am very gloomy.
I know the reason.
It is not because I seek
for what I cannot find
but because I abhor myself.
But I don't think
that disappointed ambition is
the secret to all my troubles.
Nothing to me seems
worthy of ambition.
Affect, sad fancies,
I feel dead.
I abhor myself.
Nothing seems worthy
of ambition.
Let us be honest, these
are familiar sentiments
of adolescents graduating
from college.
And not necessarily to
be too overanalyzed.
Yet they are also not what
one might expect from someone
who had judged the best
of his college class
and the most likely to rise
to a professorship at Harvard.
Child however was extremely
sensitive about his background.
He was of working class
mercantile origins.
His father was a sailmaker.
He, in his early years,
was a free flowing boy
of the Boston docks rescued by
the Boston Public School system
if ever there is a testament
for public education,
it is the Boston
Public School system.
Educated by Dick
Swell [Phonetic]
after his success
at Boston Latin.
And finally on the
basis of loans
from rich seafaring families
in Salem, Massachusetts allowed
to attend Harvard University,
at that time Harvard College.
Still the distance these
facts created between himself
and his new social
milieu rankerd [Phonetic].
Quote, we have struggled,
speaking of his family,
we have struggled with
poverty in our day
and I have always
been the favored one.
The matchless love and
patience of my father
with his cheerfulness
of intemperament
which I did not inherit has
carried us through and we are
in a better place than ever.
Now I am the main
reliance of my family.
You see my dear Ellery you
cannot easily comprehend
my situation.
You must remember
that I have grown
up in a circle entirely
different
from that of my family.
And all my tastes and
notions have been formed
under different circumstances.
Being extremely sensitive, even
fastidious, you'll may imagine
that my taste is
frequently offended
and the comparisons I am obliged
to make between my own home
and that of my friends
are mortifying.
Not only is Child mortified by
his background, feeling not as,
not only is Child
mortified by his background,
he is feeling what we in
the 20th century have come
to recognized as the duel
consciousness and status anxiety
of bright working class students
who are pulled from that class
and offered the offered
to opportunity
to be upper middle
class and professional.
However he is also frightened
of the expected sentimentality
of 1840s, 1850s middle
class life.
Quote, I am a crowd of
womanish sentiments he writes.
And they fill me up
these twilight hours
and I sometimes think that I
indulge them too much for a man.
I should hate to be effeminate
or have you think me
so my dear Ellery.
I won't make you taste
of all my bitter cups.
I had two or three
to drink yesterday.
They made me wretched
and I cannot escape
from their fascination
but drink, drink, drink.
Child's social anxieties carried
over into his search
for meaningful work.
Again he had graduated first
in his class and was recognized
by all Cambridge as
destined for great things.
At the same time he did not
have the privilege as many
of his Harvard classmates
did of waiting
for greatness to find him.
Immediately after graduation,
driven by the need to replay,
repay his undergraduate
loans, they were interest free
but nonetheless substantial.
He took the position of tutor
in mathematics at Harvard
under the great scientist
Benjamin Pierce,
father of the Charles
Sanders Pierce.
It was not a decision
he welcomed however.
He and Pierce clashed
from the beginning
and increasingly
Child loathed his need
to hold tightly to the position.
Unfortunately there was
nothing else at Harvard for him
at the moment nor was there
likely to be it seemed
for he was extremely
skilled at the work.
Quote, my examinations
were at, were excellent,
almost triumphant Ell
and Fox, a colleague,
has said that he has
never seen anything
like the scores my students get.
Still Harvard was unwilling
to find him something else
to do just because
he was unhappy.
Quote, the president hinted
tonight that I might have
to teach mathematics again.
One can feel the sigh.
And then added, but he also said
that Mr. Longfellow
has suggested for me
to take a small class of
seniors in Anglo-Saxon.
He, the president had thought
on the matter and would
like to know if I'd
be willing to be set
down in the new catalogue
as instructor in Anglo-Saxon
in Lawrence Scientific School.
Notice where he isn't being set
down and in which catalogue.
After some talk on the language
and books I've used
we separated.
The president concluding with
well I'll tell the corporation
that they must appoint
you Anglo-Saxon professor.
Happy with the new possibility
yet resigned to necessity,
Child concludes the letter.
Everybody thinks I
am a fool to give
up my chance of succeeding
Benny.
For such a [Inaudible]
and perhaps I am still,
they won't persuade me
to be a mathematician.
For all they say of very little
done to bring the old forms
of English into knowledge
if not into vogue.
And to put piling into a fence
around our fine native speech
will be more to my satisfaction
than 100 predictions of comets
and calculations of
invisible planets.
However, aware that he
could not put all his eggs
in Harvard's basket, Child
began two letters later.
I am driven to the
consideration of the advice
of many friends to study law.
There is no escaping
the argument
that if my own hope fails my one
of obtaining Edward Channing's
place, I am forever stripped
of my chance of a
comfortable future.
Very reluctantly I am obliged
to acknowledge the wisdom
of at least providing
an alternative.
Still he confessed, my soul
sickens at the thought of law.
And continued, and when I am
sick I don't get misanthropic,
I get hypochondriac.
I worry he wrote, that I
shall ever come to anything,
know anything or be
worthy of anything good.
And I should pause for a second.
That's the person writing
the letters, my apologies.
That is Child at 23.
[Pause]
Unable literally to stomach
the law, three letters later,
he turns his attention
to theology.
I had a long talk today with Dr.
Walton Ell on my prospects here,
and it was clear
when we had finished
that I had better
study theology.
I told him that most of
my friends recommended me
to the law, [Inaudible] divinity
and that the law was
counter to my tastes.
Still I recognized the necessity
of taking some profession
and little else was
left except divinity.
Of divinity I naturally said
that I had recently
thought of it.
I felt no particular
call to assume the duties
of the ministry, was not aware
of any particular talent for it
and particularly could
never enter the profession
without some higher views than
earning means of a living.
But it did not run counter to
my tastes and at least had,
I had no objection to
pursue theological studies.
The doctor openly
recommended me to theology.
He thought I should do
right to begin the study
in my present state of mind.
Ell, I must have
some profession.
And then undercutting all
of resolve he had just
written he concluded,
I can say no more
tonight my dear,
my Anglo-Saxon class
begins tomorrow.
By September of 1848 these
conventional worries were swept
aside by love.
Edward Everett, the new
president of Harvard,
had arrived fresh from
his ambassadorship
to England accompanied by his
wife and his daughter Charlotte.
In the normal course
of events Child
and she had become acquainted
and a relationship
had begun to blossom.
From casual meeting at
parties and while out walking
to surreptitiously arranged
meetings to forbidden exchanges
of letters, their relationship
grew until Cambridge took notice
and so too did Miss Everett's
parents who proceeded
to oppose the relationship
loudly and forcefully.
Child wrote to Ell, the embargo
which mama has tried to put
on our intercourse has
resulted in such, as such,
as such things usually
do infrequent smuggling.
Last week I received four
notes and this two or three.
It was easy for me
to get hers but hard
to send answers without
detection.
I had written a note or
rather two notes amounting
to nine pages of note
paper which was in my,
which I put in my pocket and
tried to deliver last night.
In the confusion of
setting, I forgot it.
She was sorry and so was I
for to tell the truth
there were some things
which would read better in
the quiet before bedtime
after an affectionate
talk and moonlight walk
than under the cold
glare of morning sun.
This morning little sis came
and took the note
increased by another page.
It was alternately merry, sad
and sentimental and sensible.
There was a description
of love in a cottage.
There was remonstrance about
affection and waltzing.
There was some mitigated
despondency.
There was some nonsense
about dreams.
And then in comment on his
confession Child wrote, Ell,
you will ask me are
you really in love?
I shall categorically answer no.
Are you going to be?
As frankly, I do not know.
I am sometimes afraid that I am.
I would not Ellery
yet I love her well.
Looking at it from cold
unchained reason I find the
business a bad one.
Charlotte is to be the only
lady whom I shall ever know.
She is generous,
kind-hearted and sincere.
She has excellent qualities
under her too frequent
affections.
She is very docile
when told of her faults
and tries to mend them.
She has a lively mind, abundance
of tact, many nice little ways
and pretty good taste.
But I am uncertain whether it
is more absurd of me to fancy
that she could love me
seriously or more dishonorable
to make me, to make her do so.
My dear Ell, do you
see my perplexity?
Do you think he dotes
and doubts?
I can't be in danger.
Charlotte would never be
so foolish as to love me
but I can't give her up.
And won't until things
look worse.
Despite his doubts, Child and
his Charlie, she has become
in the letters, his
Charlie, cannot keep apart
and he cannot stop
thinking about her.
Your letter came like, your
letter came like Elijah.
Yes I was think fasting
in the desert.
I was sick with hope deferred.
I had felt for the
first time the insipient
and half ridiculous
torments of love stricken.
On the whole, this week has
been no laughing matter.
I spent four or five hours
each day the perfect slave
of my nerves, sighing, repining,
laughing, swearing and going
through the in name phrases
proper to my condition.
Reason begins to assertive
dominion about Thursday
and now I am pretty common safe.
With a heroism invisible but
to myself I have refrained
from writing to anyone else.
Hero he might see in his mirror
but doomed lover was what
he continued to play.
Quote, I am sure through
all she is attracted to me
and would be likely, be likely
to love me if there was a way,
if it was ever less than madness
to give into such feeling.
When I think of innumerable
trials
and inconveniences I
should expose her to,
I am almost convinced
that it would be a cruel
and ungrateful thing to persuade
her to marry me if I could.
His issue was the ever
present problem again of money.
Child still did not have any.
Moreover he was unlikely
to get any soon.
He had attended again Harvard
on loans from wealthy Bostonians
who fully expected
them to be paid back.
And the Everett's
were after all one
of the wealthiest
families in America.
Child explained his
reality simply.
Quote, I can almost
earn enough to be even
and I quite can earn enough as
I work now to be happy alone.
But I have now no position
and no hope of any change
and it would seem to finish us
if I continue my
present employments.
Charlotte says she is
an expensive creature
and I have no doubt that she is.
She also says she could
live on very little,
one-fifth of what she has now.
And I partly believe that too
but I know her parents
are right.
All the world will call
her silly, foolish girl,
if she takes up with me.
Do I talk like a stricken
deer and callow heart?
I will tell you that in spite
of your counsels and concerns,
in spite of myself,
I am far gone.
Yes my dear friend
there is no denying it.
I am in love and I don't
care if you know it.
And then came the final blow.
Meet the final blow.
Age appropriate picture
of the final blow.
Confronted by the continuant
contacts and reports
of their stolen intimacies,
President Everett now
in the guise of father
Everett, quote,
desired a private
conference and informed me
that he feared an intimacy
was forming between us
which as he would not be able
to encourage it had better
stop before it goes too far.
Just that day Charlie
had written an account
of our connections and
put it on his table.
She told him that she loved
me and could be happy with me.
He expressed his
greatest astonishment.
Said he never expected
anything of the sort
and that we had better
both done wrong
in keeping the thing secret.
He calmly stated my
circumstances and my prospects,
compared them with his own
at the opening of his career,
showed the great difficulty
and almost impossibility
of our getting sufficient
means of living properly.
At the earliest he said
several years would necessarily
intervene before we could marry.
And we would be subject to the
evils of a long engagement.
He was decidedly opposed
to long engagements
because they made the choices
of young people dependent
on their chosen associations
for entering society.
Constricted the liberty of
selection, wasted their time
in sentimental intimacies or
unprofitable correspondences.
Father Everett went on to point
out the burden the wife would be
at the beginning of
an academic career.
Leaving Child in shock
and asking dearest Ell,
do you think I am
taking it like a man?
It is not for want of struggling
but I am weaker than a woman.
I faint in thoughts
100 times a day.
I long to wish with sick heart.
I am ready to do
anything for her.
I would give myself up
to the law for her so as
to have the prospect
of something better
than a professorship.
That her father might surrender.
I have no hope however that
this would make any difference.
The last three weeks have
included the most unhappy days
of my life.
My head has been
strangely disordered.
So much as to cause me serious
alarm and I begin to fear
that I should never come to
anything except the madhouse.
Interestingly, Professor Everett
sought to sweeten the pain.
The question he wrote, this is
Child to Ellery, was presented
to me last Friday by Mr.
Everett himself, with reference
to my literary career.
He asked me to come
to his office and said
that I would remember his
proposal to me a year ago
of a course of study in
some foreign university
and that time he had
expressed a desire to assist me
in removing any difficulty
which might be in my way.
Circumstances now having
changed for the better
with his wife's inheritance he
wished to renew his proposal
and would be very happy
if I would accept a loan
without inference of such a sum
of money as I might require.
He would regard it as a favor
done to him and would offer it
as a present if he thought
I would take it as such.
I told him that my plans
were in utter confusion
and that I had begun to think
more of earning my living
than gratifying my tastes
or cultivating my
familial pleasures.
I told him that my
plans and wishes as far
as they were [Inaudible]
looked toward the department
of rhetoric.
Quote, Mr. Channing has
been there 30 years said
the president.
And the man does
not hold on long
after that teaching at college.
We were interrupted without
settling anything and I am
to inform him of
my conclusion soon.
It is easy to make.
I must decline.
Agreeable as the plan is in
many respects I cannot take
on the added debt and
whether it was hypochondria
or not I have been in a state of
spirits bordering on insanity.
To come to this I have
devoted myself to walking,
to dumbbells and
to shower baths.
I even resolved to go away
to India and stay there,
to immigrate to the
west to die at once.
Oh Ell, I have been
alone on a wide,
wide sea without God
and without hope.
Life is a nightmare now.
I see the skeletons
in everything.
Despite family attempts
to separate the couple,
Frank and Charlie continued
their romance underground
alternating seeing and
fleeing from each other
across the spring and
early summer of 1849.
In August and September of
that year they were separated.
He was in [Inaudible],
she was at Newport.
Only to renew their relationship
when the new term began.
Quote, and not surprisingly
at that point Child's
hormones were raging.
Quote, I want to take
her in my arms and kiss
for an hour he writes to Ell.
She has her faults and is so
humble to entreat me to speak
of her of what I
do not like in her.
But there is so much good left
and the soul is so
worth redeeming.
I desire nothing more perfect.
I prefer my Charlie
with all her faults
to all the faultless women
I ever saw or heard of.
And in his next letter
he writes.
Quote, it is just 6:00
o'clock and I have returned
from a solitary walk
on a cold rainy night.
We had a dreary sermon about
death this afternoon Ell.
I call it dreary and yet
the man tried to make
out that death was
a light matter.
Now I have been wanting
to die all day.
And yet the sermon
did not please me.
I cannot communicate
by description the peculiar
character of my feelings
when I am in such a
condition as the foremost.
It seems as if some of
my senses have gone.
Every object is tinged
with a dark color.
I have felt the same comfortless
sensation in dreams long ago.
But never like within
this year in waking hours.
A week later things sound
even more dangerous.
But Friday night we did
transgress our ardor Ell.
We were in a quiet, quiet
little cozy corner alone.
I did draw Charlie's
head to my heart
and we shared forbidden kisses.
The next day we walked together
and we talked everything over.
We talked of being
married, of married love.
Of the early love days
of our past sorrows.
There isn't a hope.
Finally at the end of October,
1849 Child is heart-stricken
in extremists and
something must be done.
Quote, I have got through
with mewing and puking.
I have the written order
of the doctor to go.
Here is what the doctor says.
My advice to you is to indicate
this coming winter to a voyage
to Europe of such
length than and residence
as circumstances shall dictate.
My advice is based on the
observation and impression
of many cases of a peculiar
nervous morbidity to which men
who have been long
and constantly engaged
in intellectual pursuits are
not into frequently liable.
It is difficult to make the
theory of this instability
of the nervous system
very clear to persons
who pursuits have
not been directed
to these pathological matters.
But it is no uncommon
case for a person
to have the patient disturbance
of that group of organs,
the nerves indicating
in sleeplessness,
suffering without palpable
injury augmenting to neuralgia
of great anguish all without
the disease of digestion
or the circulatory apparatus.
Of half of the diseases
of literary men
in my opinion owe their
existence to an overworked brain
and the dispective
or consumptive symptoms
are all consequent.
Change, sea voyage, but
especially the abstention
from books and a
compulsory attention
to the thousand new excitements
of men and things gives a chance
to the fully, to
the full cooperation
of the obstructed parts
of the constitution.
Your complaints are now of a
moderate degree of intensity
and no different than in
a thousand literary men.
But they are a warning
and not to be neglected.
With the full resents
of responsibility
of recommending a planned
requiring sacrifices I do not
hesitate in saying the future
perspective advantages outweigh
all other considerations.
And then Child's
writes in triumph,
the corporation agrees
that I shall go.
And then he ends with what
is an amazing non sequitur.
Did I tell you of my
visit to the madhouse Ell?
I did it in a frenzy
last winter.
Two months later after a
tearful separation and promises
of constancy, Child
gave Charlie a book.
She gave him a Newport
[Inaudible].
They kissed chastely and parted
with understanding
but not engagement.
Child sailed to Europe and
began his studies in Germany.
Four months later in May, 1850,
beloved Charlie wrote to inform
that him that she was engaged
to be married in late summer.
Confronting the event in his
feelings he wrote with more
than a touch of New England's
famed emotional frost.
Quote, and now my dear Ell
having run through the facts
of the last fortnight I
will come to a subject
which I cannot avoid
to any other than you.
I could not compel
myself to speak of it.
Your surmises as to the contents
of the letter you enclosed
were perfectly correct
and before this time
the engagement
of Miss Everett has now
publically announced.
I need not say that I was not at
all prepared for such an event.
I had not received
the least warning.
The reports of her flirting
which had reached me
through various channels
affected me disagreeably
as you must have perceived from
the last letter I sent you.
I considered it very
unworthy conduct.
But that a year of such
certainty as ours in the course
of which she had suffered so
much for me and at the end
of which she fancied
herself bound to me
by every tie of infection.
And while she was bound to me
by almost every tie of faith
that such a painful year should
be forgotten so lightly was not
in accordance either
with my perceived views
of feminine character
or with the opinion
which I fondly entertained of
Miss Everett in particular.
Still I am by no
means more affected
by this second overthrow
to my hopes than I was
in December of 1848, liar.
My prevailing thought is
that I will never hazard
my peace of mind again.
Let me read that once more.
My prevailing habit thought is
that I will never hazard
my peace of mind again.
But for the desire to be,
but the desire to be loved is
so strong that my
heart sinks sometimes.
I do not deserve such happiness
and I must not think
of impossibilities.
A year later in May of 1851 in
the midst of planning his return
to Cambridge to take up
the Boylston Professorship,
Channing had in fact
retired after 30 years
of undergraduates, and
the position that he had
so desperately coveted,
Child wrote his last words
on Charlie and their love.
Ell, I have left dente
[Phonetic] to be with you.
Were you here dearest Ell?
Today is an anniversary for me.
I have a lived a year
since I received the letter
which shattered all my plans
and stifled so many of my hopes.
I can say now without
tears though my heart is
so much harder than before.
But I never would set my eyes
for those dead feelings again.
The worst is that I
can never love anymore.
You wonder if I have no regret
that I ever felt such passion
for one who did not deserve it.
Yet I must confess it
is you, only to you,
yes she did not deserve it.
Yet she was loved as the
gentlest and truest rarely are.
As every young man
with a heart loves
for the first and only time.
She is gone forever from me
and I do not regret
the loss anymore.
For those of you who feel
as if you have wandered
into a public reading of Gertes
[Phonetic], The Sufferings
of Young Werther, do not quail.
How else might one
react after listening
to an anguished lover pour out
his heart to his friend William
about a girl called Charlotte
whom he cannot have and
yet wants desperately?
The extravagance of utterance
and feeling the extremes
of exaltation and
loathing of deprecation
and grandiosity are
almost difficult to hear.
Nonetheless these
moments of injured love
and ambition are the way
some overeducated young men
of Charles generation
suppose they ought
to express themselves.
Such suffering they
thought was necessary
to cultivate originality
and of course this Child
in his historical moment is
a nearly perfect exemplar
of the suffering self
as a work of art.
And though Child does not
commit suicide as Werther does,
well I am not completely sure
as a Penn graduate I regret
he took the job at Harvard.
He certainly flings himself
about with the same bathic
[Phonetic] energy as he tries
to merge the realities of who
he is with who he wants to be.
A man, a loyal son, a
professor, an ardent lover.
He also comes to term
with life as it is and not
as it might have been.
Stiffly but sadly Child's
rhetorical identity has shifted.
Injured ambition, poverty,
status anxiety and the excesses
of love have given way
to a quiet resignation
and is somewhat measured
reflection.
An identity founded in angst and
nurtured in anguish has mutated
into the comfortable neuroses
of an ordinary pertherial
[Phonetic] life.
Gertes young romantic
genius chooses
to accept Thomas Hardy's
life's little ironies
and the frenzied almost mad
Child, like the rest of us,
settles for less hazard
and more security.
Unlike Orsino in Twelfth
Night he will have his Olivia
if he can find her and
count himself lucky.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
I should point out
for those of you
who might be slightly
worried soon
after this he meets
Ellery's sister Elizabeth
and begins a ten year
courtship with him chasing her
and her family saying
she's not healthy enough
until they finally
do get married
where upon they have four
children in seven years.
So I guess they were wrong about
that part of the family worry.
And they remained a
happy couple for many,
many years in Cambridge.
And my last picture.
This is if not the most famous,
the most important picture
of Francis James Child.
At their house in Cambridge
they had no front lawn.
It was nothing but rose bushes.
And Child was one
of the greatest rose
growers in that era.
People would come to stare at
his front lawn in the spring
and early summer when
all the roses bloomed.
He became jolly and
genial and stubby.
And I'd be happy to take any
questions if you have them.
[Pause]
This is real terror
moment, did I silence you?
>> Well were all dying for
a picture of Charlotte.
>> Oh yes.
>> Michael Bell: I just
found one about two weeks ago
in an uncatalogued folder at
the University of Michigan
but I couldn't get
to it in time.
Yea. She later married Henry
Augustus Wise whom she met here
in Washington who was an
author and a soldier and tall
and exactly the kind of person
her parents wanted her to marry.
He actually was a
famous traveler.
Nancy, yea?
>> Can you tell a little
bit about your research
about finding [Inaudible]?
>> Michael Bell: Okay.
Most of my discoveries of Child
materials is the consequence
of getting bored in the
library and not wanting to work
on what I actually
wanted to work on.
So in this particular case every
so, Child scholars like a lot
of historians periodically
just sit down at Google,
because it's all Google, and
type of Francis James Child just
to see what the most
recent thing is.
And maybe five years ago I typed
in Francis James Child and what
up popped was Elizabeth
Ellery Sedgwick Child,
University of Michigan.
And I thought that
doesn't make any sense.
What is Elizabeth Ellery
Sedgwick Child doing
at the University of Michigan?
And Michigan as libraries do had
bought a collection of papers
that were available at auction.
And I looked at the one page
not finding guide, finding guide
that said collection
includes letters
between Elizabeth and Francis.
And I thought I have
to see them.
And so my wife asked me
what I wanted for Hanukah?
And I said I wanted a
plane ticket to Ann Arbor.
And she bought me a plane
ticket to Ann Arbor.
And I went to Ann
Arbor and I stayed
in the house of a colleague.
We had lived in Ann
Arbor previously.
And I went to the library
and I opened them up.
And in the midst of all these
letters I found the love letters
of Francis James Child
to Elizabeth Sedgwick.
Of which I have transcribed
two or three
and have a small essay on.
Child's courtship habits largely
come from 2nd Corinthians
if anyone is interested.
But we really don't have very
many other documents on love
that quite do it as well
as that document does it.
At least that are not poetry.
And so I came back
to Massachusetts
and I thought well I wonder
where the Sedgwick papers are.
The Sedgwick's being an
extraordinarily famous
Massachusetts family.
They go back to Theodore who was
actually the lawyer for Mumbai,
the African American woman who
was one of the first slaves
who was freed as a consequence
of northern lawyers
challenging slave laws.
Mumbai is the only African
American buried in what's known
as the Sedgwick pie which
is the grave yard in Lennox,
Massachusetts in
the shape of a pie.
Child is also buried
there as [Inaudible].
And so I thought oh, I'll go
to the Massachusetts Historical
Society where it turned
out all the Sedgwick
papers were.
And I went in and I
looked up Elizabeth
and there were some
things about Elizabeth.
And then I saw there was a
note that said Ellery Sedgwick.
And it said correspondence
between he
and Francis James Child.
And I thought how come
nobody knows about this?
And then I thought I
found it, I found it.
And I went and literally they,
you know, they bring you the box
and they're very
wonderful and calm.
And they set the box next to
you and you're in this room
where you feel absolutely, all
of Massachusetts [Inaudible]
and puritan silence
folds in on you.
And I opened up the box and
I opened up the first folder.
And I realized that this
was an amazing moment.
We suddenly had access
to Child, the person.
And at the beginning
of his career.
Again, before he
became a ballad.
At the moment and I don't
want to make too much of that.
I mean Child's collection
stands apart from Child.
It is an extraordinary piece
of historical documentation.
But in a funny sort of way
because he never
wrote an introduction
and we never knew the man or
had a way of knowing the man.
We really lack the ability
to say anything about
the collection.
And so it stands as an
origin document for us
without commentary by and large.
There are five or six
attempts at commentary in Child
across the last hundred
odd years
since the last volume
was published.
But it really you,
because it isn't in time.
So you can't say oh well, Child
was a really great scholar
and he collected 305
ballads and X number
of variance of the ballads.
But we have long since
moved on between,
from Child's original
definition of the ballad.
None of that got said.
And in a funny sort of way
folksong scholarship ended
up being endless collection.
But it didn't have any
documentary structure
for its analysis in the ways
folktales did or ironically
in the way other
smaller genres did.
There's a generation
upon generation
of folklore scholarship
about lots of genres.
But ballads actually
sort of got frozen.
And if it weren't for
folk singers, air quotes,
they might never have been
sung since most of the people
who collected them
didn't collect their tunes
and didn't actually think
of them as sung documents.
The world of their singing
had disappeared in the,
at the end of the middle ages.
They were remembered
in recitation mostly
because they had to be
written down by hand.
And many of the people could
not note tunes so they presumed
to be recitative
documents as much
as they were singing documents.
And so in a sense as
brilliant as the moment
of his collection is it freezes
us apart from and an ability.
So think for example and I'm
wandering a bit but I'm not.
Who would essay a
criticism of a ballad today?
Who would treat it like the
poem, the sung poem it is?
Who would pick up Lamkin
[Phonetic] or Sir Hugh
and the Jew's daughter and read
it the way you would read any
other poem?
We actually lack a
critical, critical language
for that level of analysis.
We have an extraordinary
language described at structure,
to describe its form, to point
out all of its variation.
Yet in the ballad which doesn't
exist there is no single text.
So in all the text
of all the ballads
and all the work we've done
historically, to conjure all
of that structure we
would find it amiss
if we actually commented on the
beauty or the lack of beauty
of this extraordinary
moment in human creativity
where no one single voice
ever captures the poetry
of the ballad.
Even if we can't find the poets,
the poetics of that experience
and the critical value of
that experience is ironically
something that we've
been denied, I think,
by the absence of
Child's biography.
So, the more that we can do to
fill that part of the story in,
I think, more the possibility
that we might free ourselves
to begin to call public
attention not to the existence
of but to the beauty
of the ballad.
I know for a fact many
of us who are sitting
in this room found ourselves
in listening to those songs
for the first time
a long time ago.
I know that many of us can
date the moment when they froze
and we're totally captured.
I think if we can tell
Child's story we can give life
to that part that made
him dedicate his life
to the collection and
preservation of these materials.
Is that enough there?
And besides it's just fun.
It's just fun.
Any other?
>> So if I remember correctly,
this is just a chunk of letters?
>> Michael Bell:
This is, this is.
You want chapter two?
>> Did he get happier?
>> Michael Bell: He got happier.
He actually settled down
at Harvard to a career.
And he very systematically
set out.
I mean in a way that's
quite remarkable.
He became the Boylston
Professor.
I don't know if you know
what the Boylston Professor
of Rhetoric did at Harvard.
The Boylston Professor
of Rhetoric
at Harvard was a
composition professor.
He taught composition to
freshman and sophomores.
He didn't teach rhetoric.
He corrected compositions,
as in a side,
all the compositions are
there in Harvard if you want
to go see Child's corrections.
Because apparently they
didn't give them back.
He realized that to advance
he had to publish a book.
He found a book of four plays
that had never been published
in the United States that
had been badly edited.
He edited those plays,
issued that as a book
and that was his
first publication.
He then searched around
within English studies
for his next area
of specialization
and chose Chaucer.
And he did extraordinary work
on Chaucer leading to an essay
on the language of Chaucer
which is still taught today
in Chaucer classes as the
fundamental foundational text
of understanding
language both real
and poetic language in Chaucer.
And then he stopped
doing Chaucer and in one
of the letters to Ell that I've
just been working on he said
in effect, there is not
career for me in Chaucer.
The English have
the manuscripts.
Nothing I write will ever top
what they can top me with.
And he turned his
attention to Spencer.
And he wrote and produced
the first American six
volume Spencer.
But again the English
had Spencer.
And so in a late letter to
Ell, which I've just gotten
to he wrote to Ell and said
I'm going to do some books
on ballads for the
British poets.
I think I found my subject.
And so he did the six volume
British poets in the 1850s.
And then he turned around
almost immediately and did the,
started the work that would end
up by 1896 being
the five volume,
ten part giant folio English
and Scottish popular ballads.
And that bit with the reason
he dedicated it to Ell was
because Ell had the
collection of books
in which Child first
encountered the ballad
in their roommate moment
with shared bookshelves.
And in fact in this letter that
I'm looking at now Child writes
to Ell and says, do you
still have the Jamison
in your library?
Do you think I could borrow it?
And those of you who know
Child's career know he was
always writing to
libraries asking for books.
And so that's, that sort
of completes the story.
Thank you very much.
I'll be, I'll, you know,
if you want to come up
and ask questions or whatever
I'm happy to take them as long
as you can tell, as long
as you want to ask them.
But thank you so
much for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.